[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
europe le magazine européen de la
rédaction de tv 78 je suis très heureux
de vous retrouver pour cette rentrée et
pour cette reprise justement nous allons
aller dans un lycée francilien le lycée
louis basse qu'en de rambouillet plus
précisément où près de 750 tablettes et
pc portables ont été distribué à
l'ensemble des élèves de seconde une
rentrée numérique
impulsée par la région ile de france et
financé en partie par les fonds
structurels européens et qui s'avère
très utile en cas de cours à distance
notamment othman nassr ou élus
d'opposition attrapé conseiller régional
est le nouveau vice président de la
région ile de france en charge des
affaires internationales et européennes
l'occasion pour nous de le rencontrer
dans son bureau et de lui poser trois
questions sur son nouveau poste et sa
vision du sujet européen
la vision est l'avenir de l'europe il en
était également question c'est évident
dans le discours de l'union d'ursula von
der leyen
la présidente de la commission
européenne les détails de ce discours et
le reste de l'actualité européenne en
brève
c'est à suivre à la fin de cette
émission
[Musique]
ils sont presque né avec et peuvent
désormais l'utiliser pendant leurs cours
le numérique gagne les rangs du lycée en
région ile de france pour cette rentrée
2020 l'ensemble des élèves de seconde se
sont vus remettre des ordinateurs
portables ou des tablettes une
accélération du mec cofinancé par la
région ile de france et par les fonds
structurels européens depuis deux ans et
un total de 340 milles équipements qui
ont été distribués
reportage au lycée louis basse qu'en de
rambouillet ce ne sont plus désormais
des manuels scolaires qui s'entassent
mais des pc portables pour débuter les
cours comme plus de 130 mille lycéens
cette année ses élèves des yvelines
profit du virage numérique de la région
ile-de-france les très lourds et
encombrants manuels sont ainsi remplacé
par un pc plus pratique à transporter
plus adaptée à l'époque aussi ça leur
permet surtout dette voilà dans un
travail actuel collaboratif ils peuvent
échanger des fichiers entre eux avec
leurs enseignants les contacter aussi
c'est l'utilisation de logiciels qui va
leur servir aussi dans leur vie
professionnelle plus tard et qui les
préparent à leur vie étudiante en
terminale
elodie qu'il y ait melloul villa utilise
depuis deux ans leur ordinateur au lycée
une belle surtout pour prendre et suivre
leurs cours sur le fond du travail
manuel papier ou manuels numériques ça
va changer ce que le contenu va être le
même ski à avoir un petit avantage au
niveau du numérique c'est qu'on va
pouvoir stabilité des fausses sur
l'écran avec des outils spécifiques et
faire des captures d'écran pour les
intégrer notre cour quand les profs nous
demandent où va la ramener votre pc on
va avoir besoin pour les tp pour avoir
une prise nat beaucoup plus facile parce
que une transmettre des dossiers par pc
la veille comme ça en a le temps de les
télécharger pour pas avoir un problème
d'internet le jour même voulu par la
région est co financée par les fonds
européens cette numérisation de
l'enseignement secondaire est
aujourd'hui validée par la situation
sanitaire
le contexte dans lequel nous sommes
montre l'utilité d'avoir
un outil numérique c'est très important
parce qu'ils vont avoir peut-être
l'espère face policé du bascon qui est
demain une fermeture de classe mais si
des cas de kobe de supérieure à 3 par
classe sont arrivés et bien les
enseignants ne saurait pas déconnectés
de leurs de leurs étudiants et ils
pourraient continuer leur très
pédagogique
en l'espace de deux ans 340 milles
tablettes et ordinateurs ont été
distribués dans toute l'île de france
s'il ne déménage pas dans une autre
région les lycéens pourront garder leur
ordinateur une fois le bac en poche
du nouveau à la gouvernance de la région
ile-de-france othman nasro élue des
yvelines est devenu au coeur de l'été le
premier pis président en charge des
affaires internationales et européennes
c'est donc lui qui a désormais la tâche
de promouvoir la région et de gérer les
fonds structurels européens il succède à
ce poste à stéphanie van 9
nous avons profité de l'occasion pour
allé l'interroger dans son bureau lui
poser trois questions notamment sur sa
vision de l'union européenne
[Musique]
je veux très honoré de la confiance de
la présidente de la région valérie
pécresse et des élus de la majorité
régionale qui m'ont élu comme premier
vice-président avec effectivement une
mission sur l'international je connais
puisque je l'avais occupé en début de
mandature mais également ceux des
affaires européennes on a des défis
majeurs en termes de fonds européens
pour que la région récupère toujours et
c était un engagement de campagne un
maximum d'argent pour bénéfice des
franciliens pour crown est évidemment
des investissements importants sans les
prendre cet argent dans la poche des
franciliens donc l'enjeu des fonds
européens est un enjeu majeur
je suis très honoré qu'en tant que
premier vice président j'ai cette
responsabilité
aujourd'hui je suis un jeune élu qui
croient en l'europe qui pensent que
c'est à la fois une belle idée est une
nécessité dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
qu'on a besoin de cet ensemble et qu'on
a une communauté de valeurs avec
d'autres pays européens et que c'est
important qu'on puisse travailler
ensemble et mettre en commun un certain
nombre de choses ça ne veut pas dire que
tout fonctionne bien en europe il ya des
choses à améliorer aussi pour que
l'europe soit forte et soient encore
plus utile qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui
mais elle est utile et il ne faut pas
croire tout ce qui explique que l'europe
est la cause de tous nos maux
ce souvent nous mêmes en france qui ne
prenons pas toujours les bonnes
décisions alors qu'à l'échelle
européenne il y à des financements qui
existe et c'est ce qu'a fait la région
typiquement en allant chercher des
crédits européens que nous n'allions pas
cherchez suffisamment avant notre
l'europe c'est une belle chose et on
peut l'améliorer encore pour que ce soit
encore plus lucides pour le quotidien
des franciliens et des français
en ce moment il ya une discussion sur un
plan de relance européen qui viendra
apporter aussi des moyens financiers
mais déjà à l'origine les fonds
européens ce qu'on appelle francs fonds
structurels représente plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros sur la
période actuelle de six années cela
représente un peu moins de 500 millions
d'euros qui sont effectivement mobilisés
pour financer des projets en ile de
france
en ce moment nous sommes par exemple en
train de distribuer des tablettes des
ordinateurs dans tous les lycées et de
france tous les élèves entrant en
seconde auront un matériel numérique qui
leur est offert par la région une partie
de cet investissement est couvert par
des fonds européens donc c'est de
manière extrêmement concrètes te dire
pourquoi aujourd'hui c'est
l'investissement là sont utiles et
viennent nous permettent de faire encore
davantage au service des franciliens
le sujet majeur c'est de réfléchir et de
travailler à la prochaine programmation
des fonds européens à la période qui
vient de 2021 et 2027 pour prôner à la
fois une enveloppe financière à la
hauteur des défis qu'on a encore relevé
en ile-de-france qu'on simplifie les
procédures parce que les fonds européens
c'est une mécanique compliquée qui met
du temps et on nous aimerions simplifiée
par rapport à ce dont on a hérité qui
nous a fait parfois perdre un certain
nombre de crédits en ile de france il
faut que tout ça soit simplifiée et puis
pour en faire bénéficier un maximum de
porteurs de projets dans la période à
venir pour qu'on continue de préparer
l'île de france de demain
son discours était très attendu cela van
der leyen la présidente de la commission
européenne a tenu le 16 septembre
dernier son premier discours sur l'état
de l'union devant les parlementaires à
bruxelles l'occasion pour elle un an
après son élection de poser les bases de
sa vision de l'union européenne est de
s'exprimer sur les sujets d'avenir très
nombreux et climat numérique ou encore
que vie des 19 les détails de ce
discours avec nicolas landré c'est un
discours de l'état de l'union dans un
contexte particulier devant le parlement
européen de bruxelles la présidente de
la commission
ursula von der leyen a détaillé sa
vision de l'union européenne poste
qu'ovide 10,9 en fixant plusieurs
priorités en premier lieu la santé des
européens sans wim hoste continued
devons donc continuer à affronter cette
pandémie avec la plus grande prudence la
plus grande responsabilité et la plus
grande unité 10 minutes chez so for me
it s you et socrier
pour moi c'est une évidence nous devons
construire une union européenne de la
santé qui soit plus forte
yoon young conséquences de la crise
sanitaire l'union européenne a traversé
un choc économique
de nombreux emplois ont pu être sauvées
grâce au chômage partiel financée par
les 90 milliards d'euros du programme
européen sur et la commission souhaite
aller plus loin dans la protection
sociale
la commission présentera donc une
proposition législative en vue d'aider
les états membres à mettre en place un
cadre pour les salaires nous mêmes
l'union européenne de demain passera par
une transition environnementale la
commission fixe comme objectif
d'atteindre la neutralité carbone pour
l'europe d'ici à 2050 près de 30% des
750 milliards d'euros du plan de relance
seront consacrés à langues
heureusement d'ailleurs au ping pong la
commission européenne propose de porter
l'objectif de réduction des émissions
pour 2030 à au moins 55 % 4 listes
fifty-five personnes
nous améliorerons les échanges de droits
d'émission promouvront l'utilisation des
énergies renouvelables améliorerons
l'efficacité énergétique et réformerons
la fiscalité sur l'énergie a fait un bon
match mais la mission du pacte vert pour
l'europe va bien au delà de la réduction
des émissions elle vise à assurer une
modernisation systémique d'une autre
économique de notre société et de notre
industrie indienne de suite autre
priorité de l'union européenne le
numérique 20% du plan de relance seront
investis dans ce secteur plusieurs
projets dont la création d'un cloud
européens et d'une identité électronique
européenne pour sécuriser les données le
développement des connexions rapides ou
de la prochaine génération de super
ordinateurs et suite à ce discours sur
l'état de l'union la commission
européenne a dévoilé le 23 septembre sa
nouvelle feuille de route pour gérer les
flux migratoires
l'institution souhaite notamment
accélérer les procédures aux frontières
extérieures du continent et renforcer la
solidarité entre les états membres en
cas de crise avec notamment
l'instauration d'un système de
contribution flexible dans l'accueil des
migrants ce nouveau pacte a pour
objectif est d'éviter le scénario du
pire celui de 2015 et les pressions
migratoires sur les pays du sud du
continent
le reste de l'actualité européenne
s'étant brève en images avec une session
plénière du parlement européen à
bruxelles et la démission d'un
commissaire européen
initialement prévue à bruxelles fin
septembre le conseil européen se tiendra
finalement les premiers d'octobre après
la mise en quarantaine de son président
charles michel
les 27 dirigeants des états de l'union
européenne discuteront des moyens pour
relancer le marché unique après la crise
de la cobi 19
il souhaite notamment accélérer la
transition numérique de l'europe une
ambition qui s'inscrit dans le cadre du
plan de relance de 750 milliards d'euros
décidé en plein coeur de l'été
autre sujet de discussion les tensions
avec la turquie en méditer
année les 27 ont rappelé récemment leur
solidarité avec la grèce et chypre suite
aux désaccords survenus avec ankara sur
le partage des eaux territoriales sur
fond de recherche d'hydrocarbures elle
les députés européens quant eux se sont
bien réunis pour leur session plénière
mi septembre à bruxelles les eurodéputés
ont notamment apporté leur soutien à
l'opposition biélorusse suite aux
soupçons de fraudes électorales
survenues lors des élections
présidentielles les parlementaires ont
réclamé la tenue d'un nouveau scrutin et
la mise en place de sanctions contre le
président contesté
alexandre loukachenko changement de tête
parmi l'équipe des commissaires
européens l'irlande est phil hogan a été
contraint de démissionner fin août de
son poste en charge du commerce
une décision prise suite aux critiques
qui ont suivi sa participation à un
dîner de gala en dépit des restrictions
sanitaires imposées par son propre pays
phil hogan a été remplacé par sa
compatriote mairead mcguinness qui était
jusque là vice présidente du parlement
européen
ils ont marqué malheureusement
l'actualité ces derniers jours
l'actualité sportive mais pas que le psg
et l'om se sont accusés mutuellement
d'insultés à caractère raciste et
homophobe après le match qui a opposé
les deux équipes le 13 septembre dernier
le racisme comme l'homophobie ce sont
deux problèmes majeurs dans le football
depuis de très nombreuses années la
lutte contre ces deux fléaux ont poussé
de nombreux pays européens à prendre des
mesures pour lutter contre comme nous
l'expliqué olivier jean rex le
responsable du centre d'information
europe direct de saint germain en laye
les réponses apportées à l'homophobie
dans les stades en europe sont variés
l'espagne est le troisième pays au monde
à avoir autorisé le mariage homosexuel
c'était en 2005 et pourtant les
supporters ne semble pas très tolérant
la ligue espagnole a édité un guide de
bonnes pratiques et recommande la
tolérance zéro envers les
discriminations un rapport est aussi
transmis chaque semaine avec une
retranscription des insultes proférées
dans les stades et suggère des sanctions
et les recommandations sont rarement
suivies ces dernières années certains
clubs et joueurs ont pris des
initiatives des footballeurs ont ainsi
lacer leurs crampons avec des cordons
arc en ciel symbole de la cause lgbt
un club de madrid en deuxième division a
adopté un maillot barré d'une demande
arc en ciel en allemagne pas ou peu de
polémique autour de l'homophobie dans
les stades
d'ailleurs un ancien international
thomas hinschberger qui a fait son
coming out travaille comme consultant à
la télévision publique
ce sont surtout les manifestations
d'extrême droite dans les stades qui
pose problème
la société allemande est assez en avance
sur la question de l'homosexualité
cependant cette ouverture d'esprit à ses
propres limites puisque déclarer son
homosexualité pour un joueur reste quand
même un sujet table en angleterre les
autorités sévices lourdement contre le
racisme
la sanction peut aller jusqu'à
l'exclusion à vie en revanche le mot
phobie n'est pas perçue comme un
problème dans les stades mais une étude
de l'association kick it out a montré
que les discriminations homophobes
étaient en augmentation sur la période
2017 2018 sans incident ont ainsi été
recensés enfin en italie ce n'est pas
forcément dans les stades que
l'homophobie se manifestent c'est plutôt
en dehors
par exemple un joueur a été suspendu de
la coupe d'italie pour avoir qualifié
son entraîneur de paix d un autre joueur
international a dû s'excuser après avoir
déclaré qu'il espérait qu'il n'y aurait
pas d'homosexuels en sélection le
racisme est beaucoup plus problématique
en italie où les incidents sont très
fréquents les supporters adresse par
exemple des cris de singe à certains
joueurs
c'est la fin du set 8 europe retrouvez
tous ces modules et reportages sur le
site de tv 78 ou sur les réseaux sociaux
de la chaîne quant à nous on se retrouve
très rapidement fin octobre pour un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 europe a très vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]